Hey, beautiful wife
Do you think high blood sugar or low blood sugar
is more dangerous?
Isn't everyone afraid of high blood sugar?
Wrong. Low blood sugar is more dangerous.
I know an old man
About thirty or forty years ago
He usually strictly
controls his blood sugar
Insulin injection according to schedule
Blood sugar dropped too low.
A life is gone just like that.
From that day on
I always remind my patients
Don't just worry about high blood sugar
Be more careful about low blood sugar
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
The key points I share with you in this episode
Eat white rice like this
Stabilizing blood sugar to prevent amputation
Eating brown rice feel weaker
Add it to cook together to protect the spleen and stomach
Eat less to lose weight faster
careful
These unforeseen consequences
Eat white rice like this
Stabilizing blood sugar to prevent amputation
Dear sugar friends, do you know
Every year in Taiwan.
There are 6,000-7,000 diabetics
Because of foot ulcers
Wound worsening
10% to 20%
Even the legs above the calf were amputated.
Once amputated
The death rate will increase
The mortality rate within 5 years is as high as 70%.
Worse than a stroke
So scary
A good person
Why amputation?
Many people are afraid of high blood sugar levels.
Afraid to eat, resisting starch.
Big mistake
Absolutely not.
What happens if you don't eat rice for a long time?
Your body doesn't have enough energy
Easy Starvation
Immunity also deteriorates
Slower wound healing
It is more likely to worsen
The road to amputation
Rice is not a deadly food
It can replenish qi
Maintain a healthy spleen and stomach
Eat white rice
Will blood sugar rise?
Remember three tips
Let you eat with peace of mind
No sudden blood sugar surge
Tip 1
Eat in the right order
Eat protein first
vegetable
starch
Eat like this
Blood sugar rises more slowly
The pressure on the pancreas is also relatively low
There is a doctor.
He recommends
Eat meat first, then vegetables, and finally rice
Over thirty years, he discovered
He found that eating protein first
Control of blood sugar
It is very critical
Why?
After protein enters the digestive system
Stimulates intestinal hormones
and insulin secretion
Let the body get ready.
Like white rice
Or sugar or something like that
When come in
Blood sugar levels
are less likely to rise suddenly
It can also
Relieves pressure on the pancreas
Tip 2
Don't cook the food too soft
Why
The rice is overcooked
Degree of gelatinization
It is relatively high
How quickly blood sugar rises
Just speed up
So when cooking
Don't add too much water
It is better to keep
the texture a little chewy
Help slow
How quickly blood sugar rises
One last tip
Eat slowly
Blood sugar won't rise too quickly
Eating too fast will cause sugar to be absorbed quickly
Sudden blood sugar spike
More bites per bite
Then two times
Chew slowly and thoroughly
Stabilize blood sugar
Makes the stomach more relaxed
Diabetes patients
How much rice can you eat in one meal?
Diabetics or people with high blood sugar
It is recommended
that you eat about half a bowl of rice at each meal
That's about 80 grams.
Don't forget
Must match
Protein Vegetables
The correct order
Eat slowly
This will truly
stabilize blood sugar
Diabetics, please watch this episode
You can eat this tomorrow.
Teach you one more
How to control blood sugar when eating
Cold rice can really lower blood sugar
One body type should not eat it.
heard the rice got cold.
Then eat
This way blood sugar won't spike
Isn't that what your mother does?
She likes to eat cold food
It's true
After the rice is cooked and cooled
This produces so-called resistant starch
Not easily absorbed by the small intestine
Slow rise in blood sugar
It can also be fermented by beneficial bacteria in the intestines
Increase satiety
Not just rice
Cold taro and sweet potato work too.
The year 2015.
The Asia Pacific Journal of Clinical Nutrition confirmed
Cook the rice
Let cool before reheating
Significant reduction in postprandial blood sugar response
People who are worried about high blood sugar
You can try eating it this way
Remind you
There is a kind of person
It is better not to eat cold rice
People with weak spleen and stomach
What if you have symptoms of spleen and stomach deficiency?
Drinking cold water will cause diarrhea
cold hands and feet
Loss of appetite
easily tired
That's not suitable for eating cold rice.
To control blood sugar
Hot meals warm the stomach and promote good health
Eating brown rice makes feel weaker
Add it to cook together to protect the spleen and stomach
Many diabetics eat brown rice
stomach feels bloated after eating it
feel so listless all day.
Yes, no spirit
Some people are afraid of high blood sugar levels
will eat brown rice instead
Who can't eat brown rice?
If there is such a phenomenon
Flatulence and diarrhea
People who feel empty and tired
You may have a weak spleen and stomach
Unable to absorb
Such coarse and hard rice
It is not suitable to continue eating brown rice
People with weak spleen and stomach
I suggest you
Cook white rice and brown rice together
White rice replenishes Qi and protects the spleen and stomach
Brown rice provides fiber and minerals
Eat these two kinds of rice together.
Less likely to damage the spleen and stomach
Don't worry about high blood sugar
White rice is not the enemy of diabetics
It is the most nutritious rice
The Compendium of Materia Medica says
Japonica rice is the best food for nourishing people
Especially for weak spleen and stomach
After middle age
For people with insufficient blood
White rice is easier to absorb
It is the most nutritious food
don't have energy if don't eat enough
Be careful it disappears silently
You want to keep in shape
Do you eat very little
at each meal?
feel weak in calves when stand up
Climbing stairs makes your legs weak
This is because you eat too little.
Rapid muscle loss
Many people think that eating more protein
without eating will make you grow muscles
wrong
Muscle synthesis in addition to protein
Carbohydrates are also needed
To help it burn
Eating too little rice.
The body uses protein
as energy
What happened last?
Did you know
The muscles were used
Wouldn't that mean the muscles are less?
At this time, the muscles will be lost a lot.
physical strength has also deteriorated a lot.
When metabolism decreases, people become weaker.
Age faster
Traditional Chinese Medicine says pí zhǔ jī ròu(transliteration)
White rice can
Bǔ zhōng yì qì(transliteration),nourish the spleen and stomach
You don't eat for a long time
Or eating too little rice
The spleen and stomach do not have enough raw materials
There is no way to produce blood
The muscles lose faster and faster
When muscles are not strong enough
It's easy to fall
Easy fracture
Fractures significantly increase mortality
The most serious is according to statistics,
the elderly after hip fracture
30% of the mortality rate
within a year
What does this mean?
This means that three out of every ten people
who suffer a hip fracture
will die within a year.
Is it scary or not?
I'll say it again
Rice is not
The killer who makes you fat
Instead, it is your life-saving food.
Don't avoid eating rice
because you are afraid of getting fat
Eating white rice in moderation keeps you from feeling weak
Strong muscles lead to longer life
Rice is a natural hair nourisher
Not eating rice for a long time will cause edema and dampness
Many people want to lose weight
Follow a ketogenic diet
low-carb diet
Not even daring to eat a few bites of white rice.
What happens if you don't eat rice for a long time?
Before you become thin enough to reach your ideal figure
you may experience edema, qi deficiency, and hair loss.
She looks old, like a grandma.
How to say
Let me give you an example of a female star.
She used to lose weight
eat lettuce salad and chicken breast
almost every meal.
Eating too cold
Cold hands and feet, edema
Allergy problems have arisen
After seeing a Chinese medicine doctor
realized that had been treating body in the wrong way
for a long time.
The Chinese medicine practitioner told her
White rice is the highest quality protein
Can replenish qi and remove dampness
After she changed to eating white rice for three meals
Not only edema improved
Even the three kilograms gained back
have been lost.
The weight has returned to the standard figure
of almost 50 kilograms
Not only that
White rice is the key to keeping your hair
thick and black.
Research findings
No white rice for three consecutive months
67% of people experience hair loss
Why does not eating white rice cause hair loss?
White rice contains zinc, iron, and selenium.
And vitamin B7
They are catalysts that help hair grow
and produce melanin
It is a nutrient that hair
must have
And not eating carbohydrates for a long time
Blood sugar is also affected
Becoming ups and downs
There is a hormone
called stress hormones
It will burst
Hair follicles go dormant early
Accelerated hair loss
The hairline begins to recede
People look 10 years older
Eat the right carbohydrates, also known as sugars
Live long and healthy
Harvard University tracks nearly 450,000 people
It was found that people who ate 50% to 55% of their total calories
from carbohydrates lived
the longest and had the lowest risk
of death
Eating too many carbohydrates
That is more than 70%
or eating too few carbohydrates
Less than 40%
On the contrary, their lifespan is shorter
Let’s take a 50-year-old as an example.
People who eat the right carbohydrates
Life expectancy is 33.1 years
Eat too little
Life expectancy is only 29.1 years
Lived 4 years less
Would you like to live 4 years less?
don't want
You probably still want to live to 120
with the one you love, right?
yes
Research shows
Those who desperately eat a low-sugar diet
People who replace rice with meat and cheese.
Instead, blood fat soars
Increased cardiovascular risk
Higher chance of premature death
So don't talk nonsense.
Rice shouldn’t be cut off carelessly;
eating rice in moderation is the key
to living a long and healthy life.